If it's Trump, if it's Bill Gates, if
it's Bill Clinton, I don't
>> If it's the president of anything,
expose them because Adam, the truth has
to come out. Okay, I agree with you.
>> But at what price?
>> Brother, brother, just just imagine if I
said to you, just imagine as a Muslim,
>> imagine I said these words. I agree, you
know, this grooming situation was really
bad and etc.
>> But at what cost?
>> What what cost,
>> brother? So, I tell you something. They
would crucify me upside down. Yeah,
>> somewhere in Hollywood or somewhere.
>> This video is sponsored by Muslim master
inshallah to build confidence in speak
confidence is very important. Confidence
was one of the things that led me to
Islam. Not my own confidence but the
confidence of Zakin Ahmed as the
confidence that he had in his religion
made me realize why is he so sure about
what he's speaking and he made me listen
to him attentively. So guys when it
comes to confidence and how to speak you
need this in marriage, work, colleagues,
friends, giving da. So brother bro and
sisters many dice have also taken this
course in please check in the link
below. Let's get straight to the video.
Brothers and sisters and dear friends,
welcome to the Salah Pro Studios. I'm
here with Daw. How you doing?
>> Alhamdulillah.
>> That's good. Inshallah. We are going to
be dissecting brothers and sisters this
state sponsored pedophile ring. So,
alhamdulillah brothers and sisters, you
know, usually we get the far right,
Toner Robinson, the shield of Mossad and
Israel and his likes. The whole world is
waking up to the evils of Zionism and
the people who are really behind um many
atrocities and many things that happen
around the world. Zionism brothers and
sisters and Mossad being behind that and
this is just another case of that.
Subhan Allah. And when it comes to this
stuff when they accuse the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him of this vile
v this this this act and you know what
it is every accusation is a
>> confession confession. That's what it is
in. And you can see that from if you
look at it, for example, this pedophilia
situation, it's not a Muslim issue.
>> With all due respect, we don't have
this. We don't have this in our
religion. We don't have it in our
culture. This is something it's if you
if I go to Google right now and write
>> pedophiles. Yes. You're going to see
white middle-aged men. Yes. Most I'm
looking at Tommy Robinson for that
matter.
>> Across the globe.
>> Across the globe. Yes. They go to
certain countries. But anyway, Exactly.
Exactly. So, what we're going to do is
we're going to be reacting to something
so disturbing on the PBD podcast.
There's Patrick. I call him a pet. He's
a pet. Okay. He's a Patrick pet. Okay.
David or whatever his name is. A a a
sellout himself. Okay. Look at the way
they react. And you've got a full
fivestar gradea Zionist dirt bag there
which is Adam. And I need to give it to
the other guy. His name is Vivian. I
think
>> Viv V or something like that. Okay. So,
let's watch. And I want you guys to just
imagine for a moment if this was Muslims
talking about the grooming gang issue
that has nothing to do with our
religion, neither our culture. But just
look at their reaction. Look at his
reaction. Okay. Um Adam specifically.
And Adam is known to be a pro-Israeli
full-blown
Zionist. Full-blown. Just look at this.
I'm going to give you some information
uh about many people who were behind
this and they all point back to Zionism.
Here we go. Ready?
>> On pedophilia and blackmailing the most
powerful. What do you mean we are built
to find that? Do you mean our entire
country? Entire. I'm just saying our
entire I'm saying this. Whoever this is
one little operation they don't want who
whoever he was working for Epstein MSAD
CIA everything apparently the most
powerful people on the world were flying
to an island and having with underage
kids because she said it there's tens of
thousands of hours of them doing it if
we're built on that and the most
powerful people that are running the
show are in charge the guys telling
Casel oh you the thing that you just
read shut up shut up about it I hold on
you know who I am he knows who I am I
want accountability for everybody.
>> Okay. So far, I'm I'm I'm very sure.
>> Yeah.
>> Adam,
>> yeah,
>> you know, he's a Zionist. Yeah.
>> You can't get lower than that.
>> I'm sure he's going when it comes to
pedophilia
>> and children being groomed, raped.
>> Yeah. Moral compass should
>> most certainly he's going to say, you
know what? Yeah, you're right. This
should be exposed.
>> Yeah.
>> I hope you guys enjoy the video, guys.
But before that, please download the
Salah Pro app, brothers and sisters. We
are a charity. All of our services on
the app is for free. Free kibla finder,
no ads, free salah reminders, encourages
to pray, tells you salah times. You can
book a salah instructor, a Quran
instructor. You can order a guided
prayer map for absolutely free if you
want to learn how to pray salah. Videos
on how to pray salah, salah hubs, and
many, many more brothers and sisters. We
are not an app that shares your
information with third parties. All of
our services on the app is for free.
Download it now inshallah and enjoy.
Guys, let's go back to the video. Let's
see what he has to say. If it's Trump,
if it's Bill Gates, if it's Bill
Clinton, I don't if it's the president
of anything, expose them because Adam,
the truth has to come out. Okay, so I
only have
>> Okay, it's interesting because the way
he's talking, it's like he's trying to
convince Adam.
>> Yeah,
>> but but maybe Adam's already on board
with him. I mean, but let's see.
>> One question for you, my dear friend.
>> I agree with you,
>> but at what price?
Brother, brother, just just imagine if I
said to you, just imagine as a Muslim,
they accuse the groom and gans to be
Muslim that has nothing to do with
Islam. It's more in line with your
culture and your values,
>> the drugs, partying, clubbing, all this
kind of nothing to do with our culture.
Nothing to do with our culture. With all
due respect, yeah,
>> imagine I said these words and we're
discussing this grooming issue and this
or whatever and then I go,
>> I agree, you know, this grooming
situation was really bad and etc.
>> But at what cost?
>> What what cost,
>> brother? to tell you something. They
would crucify me upside down
>> somewhere in Hollywood or somewhere.
Yes. Okay. Look at
>> that's the and we've said this before.
In fact, that's the precise reason
>> the media has been crucifying
>> the politicians in this country. The far
right has been cru Elon Musk has been
crucifying people because of that
reason. Why? because oh the officials
knew about the grooming gangs in
Talford,
>> but they were looking at the bigger
picture
>> because they didn't want to appear as
racist.
>> Exactly. Now with that specific thing,
you can say, okay, they did not want the
the public safety. They didn't want
people to lash out to this specific type
of group. Yeah. Exactly. Exactly.
>> Because but here the issue is and even
that still was wrong. I believe that's
that's nonsense. Political correctness
for what? Girls being groomed. I don't
give a damn about political correctness.
But I don't give a sh I'll be honest
with you. I would even mind if they
people attacked Muslims but as long as
those kids were saved
>> so much so I would even say I because
justice in Islam the greatest form is
what justice do you get it if you're
going to blame us and call us names and
I would rather that happen to us we get
labeled we got call names when we're
innocent from it
>> rather than those girls girls girls
girls girls girls girls girls girls
girls going through what they were going
through it was a cover up all day every
day let's carry on
>> but hold hear me out
>> at what price
>> at any price so you're saying to expose
whatever happened on Epstein island
you're willing to do whatever Yes, this
looks like
>> No, I'm saying I'm Yes. Whatever price
expose these people.
>> But he's saying he's basically he's
making a conditional. Bro, this is this
is crazy. And why is he so adamant? Cuz
you need to understand what interests is
his interest that America will look bad.
>> Yeah.
>> Or the United States of Israel.
>> Yeah, that's correct.
>> His loyalty
>> is to Israel because he knows Mossad's
behind this. Just imagine guys if Qatar
>> was behind this ring an island.
>> Yes. Or Saudi
>> or this. And when when Tommy Robinson
that do about comes and says you guys
been funded by no evidence. No evidence.
Yeah. They have an issue of us da tables
being funded by Saudi. Yeah. In d what
do we do? We tell people don't drink
alcohol. Don't gamble. Don't think come
to Islam. Yeah. We don't even call them
bad. Do you get it?
>> And he says oh they've been funded.
They've been funded. They've been
funded. Here you've got Mossad. Yeah.
Getting an island, hiring this Epstein
guy who was a teacher. Yes. Who got um
>> dismissed. Yes. And then afterwards he
was working for uh who's this the guy's
name? He was working for Alan C.
Greenberg. Yes. And then he becomes a
multi-millionaire. Then he only accepts
then they only in a matter of six years
a broker. Then they start some a company
called J Epstein and Co. Yes. Financial
records were shady. They're saying that
it was shrouded. Nobody knew where it
was coming from. Okay. Except there was
only one individual uh accepted clients
who who had billion pound assets.
>> Yeah.
>> Billion pound assets. That's crazy. Who
is it? What's going on? Okay. Subhan
Allah. So the connections are there
brothers and sisters. Yes. Subhan Allah.
Which you can see. But let's carry on
inshallah with this reaction.
>> This looks like tear down the
government. Expose all the secrets. Put
America basically in harm's way.
>> Put America in harm's way.
>> Is he talking about America? It's
rubbish.
>> Is he talking about America?
>> You can't put this in America. You can't
put this in America. What do you mean
America?
>> What do you mean that the the
hardworking taxpaying people of America
have nothing to do with this? The same
way that the taxpayers in America have
been said for a very long time, we don't
want anything to do with the wars in the
Middle East. Keep our people outside.
Leave Iran alone. Leave and leave the
Palestinian alone.
>> Yes, exactly.
>> We want nothing to do with it. These are
the people that you call America.
America has nothing to do with this. And
this is what these Zionists do. They
like to tell people
>> Zionism America won.
>> No, that's not that's not true. They're
not man even Judeo-Christian values but
they're opposite oxymorons. They believe
with all due respect the Jews believe
the the the the old scripture they
clearly believe that Jesus is burning
his feces. His mother is an adulterer.
What Judeo-Christian values are you
flipping bloody talking about? You guys
are total opp total opposites. Okay.
That's the reason why the crusaders were
massacing Jews and Muslims have to
protect them because they said you
killed our God. Do you understand? So
this whole thing of infidel comes from
the crusaders. Yes. Okay. That's being
hijacked. But let's cor and and one
thing you need to buy bear in mind this
guy Adam is a Zionist Epson was a
Zionist okay his wife Max what's her
name um Gizlane or
>> Gazain Maxwell Zionist father who
randomly got killed
>> yeah Mosad
connected to Mosad
>> allegedly
>> yes so it just it just gets bigger put
America basically stop you know what I
find very interesting as well Vinnie at
the beginning he opens up and says
>> association with Mosad. It's an open
secret. Yes,
>> he said it. He said, "Oh, they're
connected to Mos." Everyone knows this.
>> Yes.
>> This is not even hidden anymore.
>> He doesn't want to talk about You can
see that's what Adam is saying that no,
no, no, we shouldn't. You know why? Cuz
he knows
>> what's coming out and it's going to it's
about to get worse.
>> Bro, your government secret services was
funding an island
>> and using those with blackmail. And not
only that, there's another video of
Patrick Pet David where there's a former
CIA agent speaking
>> and in the video you know he goes he
goes we would receive gifts from Mossad
and anytime we put them through X-ray we
heard all of them had listening divides
in it.
>> He goes we you know what he goes and you
know what people he goes I'll show you
the videos in a minute. Yeah. He goes
>> everyone. He goes every single one.
People said no way. He's like yes. He
goes we now refuse to take gifts from
>> you know they tried to do the same thing
to the the queen
>> the queen. Of course, of course. There's
this video and you should put it in.
It's a very, very interesting video.
>> Um, Tucker Carlson, he's interviewing uh
Victor Cruz. Is it Victor Cruz?
>> And he says to him,
>> "Are you not concerned that Mosat the
agency is spying on us?"
>> You know what the Cruz says?
>> He goes like, "Oh, no. That's fine.
Everyone spies on everyone."
>> Bro, they're fine with it. They know it.
It's like they have no issues with it.
You know,
>> and this is the problem that we that the
public needs to understand. these people
that you vote in for all these people
who voted in Trump. Look at now. Look
what happened now.
>> You voted in someone that you thought
that he was for you, but he isn't. He's
serveing other interest. He's serving
other entities that you're not aware of
>> because he's compromised.
>> He's compromised. Exactly. And not only
that, very interestingly, Epstein's
private jet was called Lola Lolita.
>> Lolita in Lolita Express. And I was
saying we was talking about I said
what's what's what does Lolita mean?
Where does this come from?
>> Yeah. So, it's crazy.
>> Yeah. Lolita for anyone who's into
literature. Yeah.
>> Is actually a term that refers to a
novel that was written by Victor
>> 1955 by Vladimir
>> Vladimir. Yeah.
>> Who's a famous author and the the
premise of the plot is that Lolita
>> is a 12year-old her name is in the book
and real name is not Lorita. The guy the
older man who's in like who's in love
with the 12
>> Dolores. Dolores.
>> Yeah. Dolores.
>> Dolores. gives her the name Lolita.
>> Yeah.
>> And that name Lolita
>> culturally years after had such an
impact that whenever you see
>> a woman or a girl that is young but it's
like
>> promiscuous, cute, like sexual, they
would apply the term Lolita to her.
>> And not only that, we know that Epson
used to refer to these packages that he
would give to his billionaires as Disney
>> Disney princesses. Yeah. Yeah. So you
see how deranged these people are. They
are doing this in front of our eyes.
They're calling a private jet. Uh
private jet, Lolita Express.
>> Exactly.
>> Telling you, hey, on this jet,
>> yeah,
>> we have kids.
>> And not only that, we have evidences
that well, we'll play the video is that
three 12year-old French girls were flown
out to the island.
>> There's a hearing of um Epstein being
asked about it
>> on another video we're going to come to
in. But not only that, one of the the
you know, the other client base of
Billion Assets. One of them was Lex Les
Wexner. Wexner. Yeah. And he was the
only one who worked openly and he was
the owner of Victoria's Secret. So you
see how the modeling agencies play a
role. And guess what? He's a Zionist.
>> Bro, it's like a massive mafia, bro.
>> Subhan Allah. But let's carry on
>> just to find out what's
>> What do you mean, Adam?
>> Because these are the most powerful
people in the world. They're apparently
on this island.
>> Adam, let the truth be told or the
heavens fall. I don't care.
>> These are the most powerful people in
the world. If it's a if it's a so-called
Muslim or Asian grooming, whatever word,
hell no. And to us, look, we're morally
consistent. Look at look at them. And
this is what they say. I can't remember
who was a a
>> economist. I can't remember. He said
America is strategically consistent, not
morally.
>> And America's own by who? Israel. And
guess what? He's basically saying this
is a strategic move.
>> We should not because of strategic
reasons don't justice. But when it's the
Asian community or the community, etc.,
hammer them. How could they? How could
they? But when it's the elite, yes. But
when it's our own, that's fine. They can
do it to our own.
>> And it shows you how sick society has
become.
>> So basically, when it's the weak and the
vulnerables or if it's a minority, you
target them. Yes.
>> Because don't get it twisted. Those
people, these guys, these people who
call themselves Muslims and were doing
these atrocious acts on children. I have
no sympathy, no nothing for them.
>> They're not they're not, bro, they're
not they're not they were not calling
themselves Muslims. They're not even
they were Muslim. They happen to be
Muslim. They happen to be
>> which they don't practice. Everything
they do is haram. Some of them get
capital punishment cuz someone married.
>> They'll get the capital punishment in
Islam.
>> Honestly, I would support that.
>> But what but what we've seen is is that
the the far right uses in
instrumentalizes this issue and then
hammers hijab like sisters in hijab
children, you know, Tommy Robinson, the
the case with the Syrian boy. like they
target the most minorities in in
society, but when it comes to the people
who have run this thing, he's saying
basically we can't do this because if we
put them on trial, we are destroying a
system.
>> Yeah. Exactly. So strategically
basically.
>> Yeah. Hell of it. And that's Vince
Mosana is I am 100% accountability and I
don't give if Adam if that's what we
were building on.
>> At what price?
>> At what price? Wow.
>> Brother, this guy's basically. So if
Adam's daughter was there,
>> a 9, 10, 11, 12y old girl
>> was there and they were
>> doing all sorts.
>> Yeah.
>> Would he say the same thing?
>> No. Because they value a Zionist girl's
life
>> more than anything. So he say at what
what did he say?
>> Yeah.
>> At what price?
>> Society has decided look this guy. Yeah.
He's basically he says, "Oh, America."
You see how you see now Israel, bro?
>> It's inconsistent. He says America will
have an issue. Then he says no but the
rulers is so you're not consistent even
at what price at the price that society
has decided that
>> at 12 years old in today's world you are
a child and you can't be exploited you
know we've all decided that so that's
the price that we tearing down
>> guess what the price is Adam God you
want to rule
>> you want to rule a city of ashes
>> I don't give a [__] if it's built on
pedophilia and raping kids yes Because
you're being emotional.
>> No, I'm not. I'm being real.
>> Wow.
>> Bro, bro, you you're being emotional.
Look, I don't agree with this guy.
What's his name? Viv Vinnie or whatever.
Yeah, this I'll be honest with you, bro.
This is justice. This guy is basically
saying, I don't care if the heavens
fall.
>> And that's what justice is about, bro.
To us, the biggest Allah tells us in the
Quran that the greatest form of just
speak the truth even if it's against
your own self. This guy is saying even
if against my own self, Adam say no, no,
no, it's it's about our interest. or the
hadith of speaking a form of jihad is
speaking
>> against the ruler corrupt ruler power
being
the poor thing you did the issue
>> but you want to cut your whole nose off
and ruin your entire face because you
care that much about this entire issue
is that
>> it's crazy
>> bro cut yes
>> Islam teaches that yes you cut your nose
off
>> you cut your nose off
>> the machine is running right now
>> can you pause it for a second
>> pedophile
pedophiles. I'm sorry, but he has spent
the last 3 minutes being like,
"Pedophilia, is it worth is it worth
really getting this upset and emotional
over
>> these are the guys that reacted to
basically and you can even see their
reaction to this guy.
>> They're telling him, "Shut the hell up
because we're all pedophiles. Knock it
down." And my last thing, Pat, what
bothered me about what he said is,
"We're not going to revictimize the the
girls and the victim. We're not going to
do Yes. Yeah. Cash. Guess what? Nobody
wants to see any girl. I don't want to
see any kids, male, boy, underage, blur
them out. But who's the guy that's
touching them? Who's the guy that's
molesting them and raping them? This is
a horrible argument. It's absolutely
ridiculous. I don't
>> What could you say?
>> You know what I find very strange as
well?
>> That Mr. Patrick
>> Yeah.
>> is very quiet. He's not saying anything.
>> Ah,
>> very dangerous cuz it's dangerous. He's
very careful. Oh,
>> look look. This is why he has a lot to
say about he know. Exactly. And Tommy
Robinson, you went to his pocket. Look,
these are the people, his co-host
>> saying those words.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes. And this is going to haunt you. You
know why? Let me You know what I
believe? Because these scums, these dirt
bags, they tried to label the prophetam
as that. Yeah.
>> This is I believe this is Allah subhanaa
tala humiliating.
>> If you're truthful, then be truthful.
Now, now's the time to be truthful.
>> You cared all of you cared about this.
Now's the time to be truthful because
the mess is in your living room. Clean
that up. They don't want to clean up.
>> Exactly. And look at how he's
>> smirking. Smirking.
>> What the hell are you smirking about,
bro? Was you smirking when you guys were
talking about the the grooming gang
shoot?
>> No, you wasn't. You took it dead
seriously. Yeah. And rightly it should
be. My point is this. Why is it? You
know what it is? It's like, oh, it's one
of our own done it. It's not that deep.
Look how they are dismissing,
trivializing such a thing. And then
you've got Mr. Trump here. Let's watch
him. Let's see where you're
>> still talking about Jeffrey Epstein.
This guy's been talked about for years.
You're asking we have Texas, we have
this, we have all of the things.
>> Oh my god.
>> Are people still talking about this guy?
This great guy.
>> And this is what exactly Adam said. He
said we got bigger problems.
>> We're dealing with this. It's
strategically consistent, not morally.
>> Which Yeah. Which shows you they both
are
>> thinking
>> in the same philosophy, which means for
him it might be a different reason. They
got my they got evidence of me. So I
have to play a bite. for Adam is we have
our own people here running this thing.
So we have to protect uh the interest of
Israel. That's what
>> Exactly. And I mean nothing else needs
to be said guys. We're going to be doing
more videos about this inshallah. Um and
that's big case. Big case.
>> Exactly. So brother and sisters
inshallah if you guys want us to react
to more videos please send me videos on
my Instagram inshallah and we can do
that for now. Brother and sisters any
one of them that come here and accuse us
our religion of pedophilia etc. Smack
this in their face. And not only there's
hundreds of cases, hundreds from the
church the the church of what's been
going of England of what's going on to
pedophiles in the UK traveling different
countries. This is your issue.
Pedophilia is your issue you sickos.
Okay. Alhamdulillah. Till next time. If
you want more reaction with us from
Dwood, let me from Sal Studios.